Berlin's their scene and the setting for
their graphic novels Californian artist
Rosanna kadal has lived in the German
capital for two years French writer
Mathilde calamity and Spanish
illustrator Alberto Madrigal also called
Belen home Emma Berliner and want to
stay here Belen inspires me changes me
Berlin's the best option for me right
now their chosen City inspired Matilda
and Alberto to produce the graphic novel
Berlin 2.0 its heroine is Margaux a
literature student from Paris who
fulfills her dream of moving to Berlin
first she's thrilled by the city and its
creative energy
but her initial euphoria soon subsides
as she realizes that it's hard to make a
living here is a perfect reflection of
the economic crisis we're talking about
our experiences in Berlin but those
experiences have become even more
Universal Universal Agha Vaughn attempts
and part-time workers are exploited
regularly the comic takes a critical
look at the hype that Berlin's an
affordable city where people can lead
free and easy lives today their book has
only been published in French though
Mathilde and Alberto are established
graphic artists in France Spain and
Italy still Berlin is the place they
want to be first time I came to Berlin
was for a weekend on vacation the
atmosphere was so relaxed and I liked it
so much that I decided to stay for a few
months I'm still here
Berlin's reputation of the Haydn /
artists also drew rasaan eka doll here
all the way from Los Angeles my wife and
I took a big risk and we packed up all
of our things and moved here to Berlin
having never visited the city before but
it turned out to be the very good
decision because we love it here and
I've found so many things to inspire us
here for asana kadhal berlin is the
perfect backdrop for a dark thriller
right now he's working on the think tank
series he produces with writer Matt
Hawking's the comic books are about dr.
David Lauren a brilliant inventor who
works in a secret lab developing weapons
for the US government
but he's torn between his love of
science and his conscience he lives to
create new technologies not weapons of
mass destruction think tank is published
in English and its readers are
international but in the current issue
in production a new setting plays a role
one of our main characters mere sway is
an agent for the CIA and many of our
operations take place in Berlin so get
the opportunity to draw some of the
beautiful locations here Berlin's
present is informed by tumultuous past
in Ekadasi Rilla the city offers an edgy
backdrop for a story filled with dark
foreboding
Hollywood has already come calling and
this talk that the series might be
turned into a film for artists like
Rosanna kadal Berlin is still a source
of inspiration
even if wide-open spaces like the old
Tempelhof Airport are increasingly rare
the city is becoming more built-up and
gentrification is on the rise Berlin
poor but sexy Berlin is freedom at the
risk of reality artists from around the
world are still more than willing to
take that risk the stories in subjects
Berlin offers up are simply too good to
miss
you